le premier qui prenait son téléphone et
qui négocient pour moi c'était toi quand
je me casse la gueule en scooter bas le
premier qui vient et qui me dit dans
trois secondes chez dans l'ambulance et
qui me tient la main quand je suis en
larmes parce que j'ai une minerve je
sais pas si je vais ce qui va m'arriver
parce que ça m'a fait peur bah c'est toi
quand même tu beaucoup plus bas que
d'habitude les images arrivent à me
poser toutes les questions
la lumière est une seule fois s'est
jamais si vous répondez art si vous
répondez mal ou si vous mentez à vos
chroniques attention la gauche haut bas
bas alors débarquer ce qu'on a vu la
fameuse enquête débat vous dis toujours
que vous ne découvrez les images que à
l'antenne oui quel est votre degré
d'intervention dans nos chroniques dans
ce qu'on peut transmettre à la prod
chaque jour qu'est-ce que vous avez pas
d'un tir 0 0 parfois formés 0 jamais pu
vérifier 0 un but à hénon ipad un terme
aux ipad intéressante mais rien de
précis alors vous avez comme si vous
travaillez vous dites dit un petit mot
sur la saison et vous me posez une
question bénin moi j'aimerais dire un
petit mot sur sur sur vous non il sera
sur son voile a surnommé sur voila moi
je vais franchement dire sur la vie sur
vous deux sur nous deux sur eux ce qui
vous arrive non parce que vous savez
très bien chez resserrer les liens qui
nous unissent et je voulais non mais je
voulais en profiter de déguiser mais non
mais de ce petit moment un peu
l'ensemble en thèse ou de leur dire non
mais pour vous dire à quel point je vous
trouve un garçon formidable est un
garçon droit non très sincèrement parce
que ya évidemment le beau le patron le
producteur que je trouve brillant et
puis il ya l'homme qui est mon ami mais
mon frère est vraiment laid qui a
toujours été mathieu a parlé hier de
personnalités qui sont rarement les
mêmes et avec qui sur qui on peut
compter
nous on sait tous ici moi je pense
parler au nom de mes camarades qu'on
peut compter sur vous en dehors de la
mission
[Applaudissements]
c'est une fraction de c'est une façon de
te dire que je t'aime moi aussi je
t'aime fort mais je crois que j'ai déjà
signé
alors là que ma question est la suivante
on a traversé quatre petites polémiques
l'année dernière et donc je voulais
savoir comment est ce que vous aviez
comment ce que tu avais démarrer la
saison
est-ce que tu étais un peu stressé
angoissé est ce que tu voulais entre
guillemets démarrer différemment et
comment est ce que justement tu fais le
bilan de cette saison
alors non non non on a eu ces réponses a
eu des polémiques l'an dernier on est
arrivé on était tous très contents de se
retrouver mais c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
voilà on était tous un peu savaient pas
si on devait déconnez pas déconner ça a
bien marché secondaire aa à se lancer
et c'est vrai qu'on a voilà je vous ai
dis juste un truc et il faut juste faire
une bonne émission
ne vous inquiétez pas tout se passera
bien mais c'est vrai qu'on était un
petit peu stressé cette saison plus que
les autres années parce que vous voulez
changer beaucoup de choses
et en fait après on est revenu on sait
faire voilà et haslem faire donc c'est
vrai qu'au départ voilà on tâtonnait un
peu et c'est vrai que la première
émission que vous verrez demain puisque
on fera sur le prime on retiendra aussi
sur tout ce qui s'est passé cette année
n'a rien à voir avec l'émission de ce
soir mais je préfère nettement
l'émission tout ça voilà donc michael
merci d'être là ou alors c'est bon les
filles vous avez vos adorateurs vous
avez vos détracteurs pour moi vous êtes
la rock star du paf vous observent
depuis deux ans et j'allais dire que
c'est un espace de liberté absolument
dingue pour pour moi et pour nous tous
je suis absolument jamais d'accord avec
vous mais j'aime votre mauvais goût
j'aime vos colères non mais c'est ça qui
est bien c'est pas non plus on est plus
ou viande est alors faite mais vous
voulez finalement qu'on s'exprime et je
trouve que c'est extrêmement précieux
extrêmement rare tous les soirs deux
heures à la télévision et donc je vous
en remercie et moi c'est une expérience
absolument inoubliable et fabuleuse pour
moi on reste avec nous l'an prochain
mais j'espère l'instant rien ici bien
sûr que je veux pour acheter avec j'aime
votre mauvaise ou spams à la merci vous
avez une question posée oui je vais
savoir l'année a été un peu compliqué un
peu conflictuelle entre jan barta c'est
vous et il veut savoir quels étaient vos
liens aujourd'hui votre relation avec
lui parle pas du tout imad échanges de
sms pas de vous devez tout dire vous
êtes sur le ferai dès la vérité j'ai dû
l'envoyer de trois sms
ouais mais maintenant il m'a jamais
répond qu'il n'apparaît pas de réponse
d'amd pas des litchis amener des
réponses mais il m'a jamais répondu
voilà donc on se parle pas du tout
c'est chacun pour soi traitent chacun
chez soi et les vaches seront bien
gardées
oui enchaîné parce que c'est lié oui
alors moi la séquence émotion la frappe
de même parce que deux jours de suite ça
va être trop donc là je voudrais me
concentrer le conducteur alors oui les
me rassure en fait concret mais qui est
lié sait les audiences c'est mon boulot
de ci de là regardez moi à airtel
puisque ici encore et donc les audiences
depuis janvier elles sont constamment en
tête les autres qui sont pas plus cons
que moi ils les regardent aussi dans les
autres chaînes
est-ce que du coup ils nous ont
davantage contacter que l'année dernière
par exemple est ce qu'ils on vous en
fait des propositions plus ou moins
concrètes dans les autres chaînes
non mais je vais vous dire déjà tf1
parce qu'il était l'acte auront pas maso
franchement il n'ya aucune chaîne qui
m'a appelé je vous dire tout le monde
sait que je suis je suis ici pour moi
[Applaudissements]
consécutive la comptable a tu le record
de 30,6 si je devais faire ça non mais
donc autant que leur manière mais c'est
vrai qu'ici ils voient la jce il mais
ils n'imaginent pas partir de ces huit
séries que j'ai de très bons rapports
avec m6 et que si un jour je le dis
toujours si un jour je dois partir de
deux de ses mythes ou voilà du groupe
canal+
voilà ce serait pour aller dans le
groupe aime cette ville va s'infléchir
est trop vieille et bat avec plaisir
qu'a dit oui tony
alors moi je voulais vous dire que j'ai
passé une super saison avec vous je suis
ravi d'avoir fait du toit liés alors
fais ta rencontre au mans pour moi
c'était génial je vécus des rêves j'ai
vécu des dards cas de ouf et d'amour
et voilà moi je voulais vraiment le
souligner parce que depuis début tu m'a
accompagné tu m'a conseillé tu m'as tu
m'avais très bons conseils et c'est
grâce à ça que j'étais à l'aise dès le
début voilà je vais t'en remercier ma
mère si tu te sens pas si j'ai une
petite question je voulais savoir
qu'est-ce qui pourrait te faire arrêter
la télé plus forte qu à devoir vous dire
non non non franchement si si pour
l'instant on s'amuse tellement l'année
dernière on a eu tellement de polémiques
tellement de gens qui nous chercher des
poux dans la tête je me suis posé la
question d'arrêter d'être un moment où
est de passer et d'arrêter tous d'accord
d'arrêter de faire du tennis faire
d'aller voir les gens voilà qui fait
avec eux faire des baby foot dans des
bars tout ça voilà
normalement je me suis posé la question
mais cette année plus voilà plus
franchement
mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment je me
suis posé la question peut-être
d'arrêter l'année dernière mais là cette
année plus tôt mathieu alors moi j'aime
pas trop si c'est préventif
tu sais maman cet exercice effectué à ce
que j'aime chez lui mérité 6,3 du
cachemire non je pense que c'est depuis
je sais pas peut-être en quoi ma plus
belle année pour moi après je dis que je
parle pour moi ce que j'ai ressenti moi
parce que comme amanda lear je ne suis
bon à l'antenne que si on même est là
pour être très sérieux cette année tu
m'a beaucoup donné et donc j'ai vu sans
doute mais aussi non mais tu ferai ce
que je veux dire
cette année je me suis senti aimé voilà
j'ai donc ça s'est très bien passé et à
québec mais rien à faire
et puisque je veux dire aussi c'est
qu'est ce qu'on voit à l'antenne ce
qu'ont les bêtises qu'on fait mais
est-ce qu'il ya hors antenne et hors
antenne moi ce qui m'a beaucoup touché
c'est que que j'étais un peu en galère
pour signer des produits des machins le
premier qui prenait son téléphone et qui
négocient pour moi c'était toi quand je
me casse la gueule en scooter b le
premier qui vient et qui me dit dans
trois secondes chez dans l'ambulance et
qui me tient la main quand je suis en
larmes parce que j'ai une minerve je
sais pas si je fais ce qui va m'arriver
parce que ça m'a fait peur bah c'est toi
quand même quand il ya un connard qui
m'agresse ou qu'ils m'insultent sur
twitter ou au téléphone dans la seconde
je t'aime république j'ai vu qu'elle
[Rires]
[Musique]
un truc que je traîne touchant c'est que
parfois tu nous engueule dans les loges
parfois voilà quand il ya un truc que tu
ne supporte pas c'est quand d'autres le
font c'est qu'éventuellement toi un jour
nous traitait mal parce que tu es de
mauvaise humeur pourquoi pas mais si
c'est quelqu'un d'autre quelqu'un
d'autre qui le fait pardon ça ça passe
pas et tu te pardonne pas donc il ya ce
côté
voilà qui moi me touche beaucoup parce
que c'est que malgré tout à chaque fois
que j'ai besoin que j'ai eu besoin ou
que j'aurais besoin et même après les
pires engueulades tu seras là et tu t'es
là et donc ça ça me touche beaucoup
non ça c'est fait s'est il en sera
toujours comme ça quand la question est
alors la question si tu devais écoute
bien sinon toute ta famille brûle si tu
devais là parce qu'il ne fait pas de
réponse à l'algérie les chiris pape
aussi michel si tu devais absolument
ne gardez homme ou femme que deux
chroniqueurs dans cette émission à la
rue l'année prochaine la saison selon
après sept années passées un pas sur les
dix ans après ce que tu as vu cette
année tu ne te regarde et que deux
laboratoires chaîne tous les autres
faudrait renouveler qui te garde les
deux mais je prendrai les deux moins
cher c'est ça que s'attaque à la vraie
vie la vérité fondation chérie la
proximité attention non mais bon je ne
devrais pas dire la vérité il doit être
ça diraient joua les deux moins cher non
les deux historiques dedans tu pourras
dire deux historiques pour interdire de
coeur tu joues énormes et il prendrait
les deux normes et les deux filets de
sécurité de plus les deux plus anciens
en vrai je suis obligé de garder de
penser isabelle et jean qui est à
isabelle janvier chez jean louis
bélanger que jean-luc nommé juge les
plus anciens et jean-michel ça fait
plaisir
parce que jean-luc voilà je les ai dans
mon ami c'est toujours avec moi même
mais même à la maison d'arrêt messi ou à
la vallée d'argent les chaînes déjà vu
puisque c'est les deux puces voilà bravo
voilà bah quoi c'est vrai mais
franchement pour moi c'est les deux
meilleurs donc les bras merci par lbo
alors
[Musique]